alors franck et lit on va tenter
maintenant une première à la télévision
l'interview ventriloque c'est la
première fois que ces tentes et elie tu
fais la voix de dubosc du buzz que tu
fais la voix d'elie donnez vous la main
et bien entendu vous appuyez sur la main
de votre partenaire quand il ouvre la
bouche vous êtes près voilà attention
didier
[Musique]
alors on va d'abord vérifier si ça
marche elie comment ça va ça va plutôt
pas mal enfin c'est à dire que ça
pourrait aller mieux mais ça va quand
même beau mâle j'ai vraiment fort et
villefranque la forme
aubin ça va moi disons qu'on est toute
une équipe
on est mais on aimerait bien être
plusieurs
j'sais pas si vous comprenez bien ce que
je dis si si si franck dubosc vous le
trouvez vos ou drôles
robin je le trouve beau et drôle je
trouve tout à la fois c'est un être
extraordinaire
est-ce que était pas plus drôle
finalement quand il veut c'est que
dieudo manison j'estime que quand j'ai
connu et lis ça a été décevant une
révélation pour moi et je me suis
demandée pour qu'est-ce qui fait avec
cette personne de couleur
elie vous préférez quoi chez franck et
sa carrure le dire c'est quand même un
gars qui est bien foutu c'est un homme
intelligent c'est un homme qui a de
l'avenir c'est quelqu'un que j'aime en
coup là ça commence à me faire chier de
parler autant que ça alors les bénir
poker et vous
et vous font que vous préférez quoi
shelly moi ce que j'ai toujours aimé
chez lui c'est sa sensibilité
c'est sans talent et c'est son
intelligence j'ai remarqué une chose
extraordinaire chez lui les démarches
qu'ils des mois parce qu'à cause de la
prime
j'ai toujours trouvé chez lee ce talent
inné et inhérents et j'adore votre
disque vous le savez j'aime beaucoup
vous la chanson qui est en promotion
comme par hasard est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en faire un petit bout a cappella
aubin pour vous en bas pour vous en
faire un bond en battant assez mois
il y
où
il est fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
comme du buzz vous avez que vous êtes le
rêve de la haye - cinq ans de la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans chère à nos
amis de tf1 vous leur dites quoi aux
ménagères de moins de cinquante ans
quand vous les draguer dans les
supermarchés frank baasner dit que les
emmerdes dit lequel de vous fera un bon
film en premier
si trop peu à peu dans mon attention et
vie lequel de vous fera un bon film en
premier ben je crois que tu vas tu as
compris sa blague à la cour font que
lequel de vous deux cas un bon film en
premier abbas est évident que c'est moi
troc banques
auxiette chaude-pisse s'est passé non
c'est pas encore passé j'ai encore des
soucis j'ai été opéré la semaine
dernière on a angers
la moitié de mes parties génitales c'est
pour ça que ils ont le rôle que
j'interprète en général de playboy est
complètement sûr fait j'étais d'accord
avec ça et lee quand vous pensez ça n'en
fait pas cas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu